on your math quiz you earn five points
for each question that you answer
correctly and the table above
q
represents the number of questions that
you answer correctly on your math quiz
and p represents the total number of
points that you score on your quiz the
relationship between these two variables
can be expressed by the following
equation
p is equal to 5q where p is the points
you get and q is the number of questions
you answered correctly and you could see
that in the table if q is zero if you've
got no questions right you get zero
points if you've got no questions right
well five times zero is going to be zero
if you get one question right well one
times five is five you get five points
per question two questions right well
two times five is ten two times five is
ten
three times five is fifteen so this all
makes sense so then they ask us which of
the following statements are true check
all that apply
so let's think about this they say the
dependent variable is the number of
points you score
so when you think about what's happening
here is your number of points you score
is being driven by how many questions
you get right it's not like somehow the
teacher says you got 15 points and now
you have to get exactly three questions
right the other way around the number of
questions you get right is the
independent variable and that's driving
the number of points you score so the
number of points you score is the
dependent is the dependent variable and
typically the convention is is to have
the dependent variable being equal to
some expression involving the
independent variable and you see that
right over here p is dependent on what
happens to q
depending on the number of questions you
multiply it by 5 and you get p so the
dependent variable is the number of
points you score the dependent variable
is the number of questions you answer
correctly no we've already talked about
that that's the independent variable
the independent variable is the number
of points you score
no that's not right that's the dependent
variable the independent variable is the
number of questions you answer correctly
well that's right that's what's driving
the dependent variable and we can check
our answer